we're social animals it's there's no
getting around it we seek belonging yeah
right and I'll give you a funny example
of how it works so where do you live
where were you right now I'm in San
Diego okay so you're in San Diego are
you friends with everyone in San Diego
of course not that's ridiculous
I know where you going because I use
this too but but if you go to San
Francisco and you meet somebody from San
Diego you're like I'm from San Diego and
you guys are like and then when you're
in New York and you meet someone you're
like I'm from San Diego they're like I'm
from Los Angeles you're like you're both
in California that's right right and you
go to Paris and you're on the Paris
Metro with your family on vacation and
you hear an American accent and you turn
around say hey where you guys from
you're from Wichita we're from San Diego
we're best friends
cuz that's human beings we seek out
people who have shared values shared
understanding of how we grew up shared
experiences and we create tribes because
we're safer in tribes and that
personally you just met on the Paris
métro that tourist family will say oh my
god have you eaten at this restaurant
and you go no and then you will go to a
restaurant because tourists told you to
but if a French person just random
stranger French person told you to go a
restaurant you'd be like that because
there's no trust even though they're
much better qualified to give you
restaurant advice than a random person
from Wichita metro yeah that's my point
which is we trust people that we're in
the tribe with you know for better or
for worse and so ideally you want to try
to form around vision and values right
so Marines if you meet Marines Marines
always talk about the intangibles
they're constantly talking about the
intangibles there is no meant the
intangibles what they mean is the values
the trust the love the brotherhood the
sisterhood the honor the courage they're
a values-based organization and they
understand that what makes them a unit
are the intangibles just like in your
relationship what makes you love your
spouse is not that they're pretty that's
nice what makes you love them and trust
them
the shared values the shared the shared
understanding the shared vision right
and so when we give an organization a
sense a really clear sense of cause and
it's a values based organization it
doesn't matter what our politics are but
if you take away any sense of vision or
cause what ends up happening is we start
seeking out tribalism tribal connections
based on anything that we can see easily
so you can get racial divisions great
political divisions you get all of these
stupid things that really don't matter
amount to anything and usually the
greater the division based on
superficial or political lines it
probably means that we are not being
offered a sense of global vision and
something that unites us in common cause
because you know what it's like
take take any take any city that has a
natural disaster earthquake tornado
hurricane whatever it is all of a sudden
politics goes away class goes away
racial divisions go away and we're all
taking care of each other and we're all
helping each other that shared
experience shared experience shared
hardship is actually something that
releases oxytocin we talked about that
chemical that creates those magical
bonds shared hardship actually creates
common understanding and so the fact
that we are all going through this
pandemic good leaders will talk about
how we're all suffering and we all have
to help each other right because again
it's the light at the end of the tunnel
speech we are in somewhere dark right
now
you know optimism is not is not the
denial of reality right that's
positivity we don't need that like
everything's fine everything's good what
are you talking about look at all this
opportunity you're insane this is
no no that's positivity that's not
helpful that's ignoring the reality
optimism is the belief the undying
belief that the future is positive but
we can talk in realistic terms about
what we're going through now yeah and
the fact is it will be over it will end
we want it to end sooner rather than
later and we want it to end with as
little loss of human life as possible
and we want it to end with our doctors
and nurses
mentally healthy when they come out of
it like weird we need to we need to work
on those three things but at the end of
the day it's gonna end yeah it's gonna
end it always does
that doesn't mean denial of difficulty
that doesn't mean that it's not struggle
but it means now that we can start to
work together to work through this and
and reinvent our companies and reinvent
ourselves
[Music]
you